little gray I'm gonna walk into place
behind you darling the Cata three throw
it behind you and look at it as it
travels in the air ready one two go for
a competition gets lice
love that guys keep on going always
there
and dad snuggle your face right into
hers there and guys what I want you to
do in that position without talking I
want you to just say that you love each
other without talking just with your hug
and your embrace is do that for me what
did you tell me
hold it with your hand like that and
just eyes down and close your eyes for
me like that perfect gorgeous that's
nice
I know
intend 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 and
then the tender
Niki's the temple it might and I was
down darling
Just Breathe three mouths just really
subtle therefore we do beautiful health
there
that's it beautiful and now turn your
face extreme that way
that's good chin down and eyes down
that's perfect don't move hold it hold
it
all right beautiful Bobo over here no
I'm still obsessed with these moments
first tilt back this way I'd take you
mother
you
roughly set you up and then I get my
technique right so never sort of say hey
what do I do because we might miss a
moment or a feeling if I want something
I'll always ask for it and very gently
just want you to peer off to the left
there to the window and a bit higher
there very gently just your eyes of me
actually we'll do that again is I think
your body look at what looks great here
- with that - so just turn your face
more that way that's beautiful that's
gorgeous really soft
ok again to lean fortune up as fast as
you can spin it around and look at the
girls that's it and faster faster how
awesome is that
Hey look at the blur umbrella and
everything focuses so pretty pretty
pretty
Jardine so I stored right cut right
there
okay that's nice that's pretty good that
way that I lose that vehicle
yeah that's nice and push it aside lose
accentuate the net chemistry
oh nice
I want since that I want full exactly
yeah
I love
as many people know five years ago we
did a little something at our wedding
that got us a little bit of publicity
across the world we were on The Oprah
Winfrey Show and I ended up dancing with
Patrick Swayze so our fifth anniversary
was coming up and we thought what can we
do that will outdo doing the dirty
dancing dance and dancing with Patrick
Swayze on The Oprah Winfrey Show I know
a shoot with Jerry Guyana's I saw an
Oprah Winfrey myself I was jealous I
actually wanted to dance the Patrick
Swayze myself so I was whew I mean to
dreams of mine were someone else
fulfilled I wanted to be on Oprah and I
wanted to dancer the Patrick Swayze so
I'm very upset and jealous but that's
okay okay you can test me thank you
please thank you I'm inspired by music
and fashion and there was a recent music
clip from Katy Perry called thinking of
you that I thought was really really
cool in a star that of course it's Julia
in terms of the vintage fashion and and
all that beauty and glam and all that
kind of stuff that she does and also
what I'm attracted to as well oh damn
you blinked no joke
that's perfect that's all I wanted done
like chin up and turn your face towards
me and that snuggle adds perfect
shot was really fun even though I think
I have permanent damage to some muscles
from holding the pose look how many
people are it's ridiculous it's awesome
it's a big testament to how much I
actually trust Jerry to the fact that he
got me into underwear in front of him
because I barely dress up it's not the
first time I knew that if there was
anyone in the world that I was going to
get into you know sexy lingerie in front
of it was going to be Jerry be honest so
I pressure that to make you feel
comfortable just letting the viewers
know I actually was in my underwear as
well yeah it was the gram it was it was
fine you know I mean it's all good
that's really cute love that that's
awesome
you
you
what smart people to follow their dreams
they can do it as well mate it's
fantastic you know it's it's it's a
beautiful thing we did win for everybody
give me a cute little giggle there
darling there you go there we go a nice
Dallas he's doing that love that she
knows how to do that
you know whenever you want anything from
your husband you just do that whole do
sweetie
Carly can mask you look yeah just hold
that for me something like that just
right where I am the same way both hands
out like that
eyes down gorgeous beautiful Wow
really soft sweaty really soft really
soft close your eyes a second close your
eyes I love that look at that wind here
we are in Melbourne and we have stumbled
across the graffiti wall square feeding
keep on holding like that looks really
cute that don't move don't come any
closer in for dolly chin up a little bit
you never giggling look at your man
that's it
Oh
getting it again
your queen all right beautiful sweet
very case of them and the governor shot
exactly so very gently if you sit this
way that is a beautiful though that's
gorgeous I move a beautiful
and both look at our numbers event
so second team I'll bring the boy closer
then it's struggling that's it
production Olivia
and love you mom look at your mom that's
it that's it beautiful now a bit more a
bit more then what is that bit bit more
you're comfortable beautiful guys hold
it there put the kiss guys and close
your eyes hold it that's it now just
lean forward towards me both of you
that's it beautiful
I need laughing I need giggling I need
laughing squeezing it easy guys if you
can bit taller and eyes down guys
hey Jess
try try bouncing it towards you or close
your eyes and bounce it off your face
ever that sounds stupid but it might
work closer close your eyes
sit up straight darling guys tall the
taller taller eyes down is in fact close
your eyes both of you and chin up
building a bit of a smile there a little
bit of subtle smart beautiful iris I
want you were just chillin Thank You
second let's light the cigar again once
ago again
right light it for me just of the light
tilt your head to the right mate
cut you that way that's it okay all
right very quickly I need one of you to
pose somewhere here pose actually come
perfect and one a bit lower once again
be watching us and two of them two on
this side
can I have you a bit higher and a bit
lower you can set perfect
I need a silhouette like this perfect
perfect and I'm in a bit lower nothing
come a little bit this way perfect
beautiful everyone I want all the dances
look at the bride and groom guys look at
each other don't move
okay guys look that's it beautiful over
there
rowdy group kiss
Oh
Oh
Oh
yeah
Oh